[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
viens 20 ans quand comme tous les ans
nous essayons de convaincre d'autres
mécènes ce chemin nous avions à
parcourir tous ensemble nous a fait une
proposition étranges surprenantes qui à
aiguiser notre curiosité nous a fort de
ce qu'il entendait de nous amoureux de
notre quête sur l'harmonie ensemble la
complicité et la fluidité et nous a
demandé d'aller dans ces équipes dans
son entreprise partager notre expérience
de musicien
il nous a juste dit par les musiques
arts est ce que vous savez faire garder
de votre quête ne changeait lien il
comprendre la métaphore fera son oeuvre
c'est ce chemin que l'on aimé retracer s
avec vous aujourd'hui
en quelques autres petits secrets que
l'on a choisi parce qu'il faut que vous
sachiez que quand on commence à jouer
braqueurs d'avoir quatre professionnels
qui ont beaucoup travaillé seul chacun
dans son coin vous préparez les
partitions qui sont quelquefois
intéressantes comme celle de dieu sait
quand même
c'est simple sur ses listes évidemment
ou celle de léo et on se demande
pourquoi il a fui tant d'années aussi
c'est peut-être en soi qui a le trésor
caché
[Musique]
je vais être obligée de zapper que sa
personne je vous remarqué que le premier
noyau vous par exemple qu'il va petit
c'est vraiment quand vous allez au
concept vous avions donc beaucoup de
chemin pour me laisser quatre
savoir-faire et réalisé l'équipe de
notre rêve
nous avons commencé à répéter il et
d'ajouter c'est qu'un semblant faire
[Musique]
il ya vingt ans quand il passe des
heures pour chercher comment déjà
s'organiser s'organiser en voiture c'est
tout tu viens faire certains imaginent
qu'on a un chef général parce que ses
premiers mots mais ils se trompent quand
même un petit peu parce que notre seule
richesse et le compositeur celui qui
vaut vivre notre feuille de route et que
nous n'aurons de cesse servir suivre
dans ses consignes donc pour mieux
suivre le compositeur nous allons
saint-victor devons partager des
responsabilités
ils ont appris pendant les répétitions
on doit soigneusement choisis qui fait
quoi par exemple tous les bus c'est mon
fils à tout moment puis c'est moi qui
dirige la seconde note et je reprends
tout de suite
[Musique]
vous aurez compris dans un pagne or il
faut aussi bien savoir observer recevoir
les consignes des autres que donner
toute son énergie pour faire avancer le
mouvement
cette relation d'interdépendance va
grandir entre vous pour pour qu'une
vraie fluidité et une impression de
sécurité puissent apparaître dans notre
musique c'est alors vraiment important
des communiqués à l'intérieur d'une
voiture quand nous répétons nous on
utilise ou non très rarement les mots
parce que nous avons d'autres moins bien
de connu nous allons maintenant jouer
une vraie répétition avec tous les
outils communication pour que l'huissier
les observer et voir ce que nous mettons
en oeuvre pour aller très vite
là cette unité c'est un jeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les musiciens se regardent vous avez pu
observer que nous sommes obligés de me
regarder
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nos publics
sont en bas alors qu'il comporte tout
notre technique et qu'on aimerait bien
les plus proches pour voir se raccrocher
aux branches les noms qu'on regarde en
priorité quand on est musicien
parce que on a besoin de ré venir les
autres de la prochaine fantaisie que
donc on a décidé d'initier dans le
propos donc ces regards cette
anticipation vague l'élément un des
éléments extrêmement importants de notre
liberté
on a besoin de prévenir pour rester
ensemble même si c'est pas naturel dans
notre dans notre formation de musiciens
mais regardez ne suffit pas et je dirais
même que nous avons un socle commun qui
est fondamental quand on est musicien de
quatuors c'est une certaine forme quand
nous écoutons nous avons à capter ce
qu'ils proposent bien sûr mais une fois
qu'on a un passé qu'on a entendu ce que
l'autre propose qui sera le plus
important c'est de suite qu'on aime
qu'on passe en position ces propos des
répétitions une sorte d' écoute
bienveillante une sorte de solidarité ou
quoi qu'il arrive nous suivrons les
autres figurez vous que c'est la crise
il un des secrets de notre confiance
certaines personnes un public imagine
que nous sommes nés pour être ensemble
ou que nous sommes de grands
professionnels toujours parfait non pas
parfait on fait que corriger en
permanence pour que vous public vous
n'entendez pas les défauts notre écoute
c'est très rapide et s'adapte en
permanence ce qui est proposé par les
uns et par les autres
c'est ce qui commence à animer ils sont
deux passions dans le bus dans le dans
une voiture écoutez nous demande
si de décentrer et nous demande de
changer nos habitudes nous avons
beaucoup d'habitudes y compris des
attitudes gestuelle n'avait pas imaginé
que nous sommes aussi sage à l'état dans
ma vie nous avons bien dans le quatuor
un violoncelliste légèrement fumé ans
qui aurait tendance à être au fond de la
chaise des fossiles un altiste
complètement déjanté quelle tendance à
partir en inventions créative à tout
moment un deuxième violon très
analytique qui ne trouve c'est beau et
bien sûr je garde pour la fin la place
du premier but manqué celle des motions
si nous n'avions pas si nous n'avions
pas travaillé sur une certaine
simplicité de notre posture corporelle
et antisémites et ça veut dire que nos
égos surdimensionnés ont lâché quelques
certitudes il ya nous ne pourrions pas
communiqué faisons nous serions devenus
une sorte de quatuor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chercher leurs revenus ensemble ça veut
aussi dire la chaîne d'habitude chacun à
travers un travail même voir porhel
brésil simplifier sa gestuelle pour que
l'on se retrouve dans cette transparence
la communication va pouvoir apparaître
de plus en plus dans le du coup on se
sent très dans notre histoire
cherchez la puissance ensemble et c'est
un compositeur on demande par exemple la
zone of brothers russes ont une voiture
ça où il est question de fortis immo et
d'être puissant ensemble nous sentons
fort bien préparé
veuillez donner ce résultat pour le
servir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
bien sûr si on ne vient pas parler on
peut se permettre de tout donner
n'a pas connu sa main son équipe ce qui
est un peu déroutant c'est contient mois
la tête et personne en face d'un tel
atout réside entre notre énergie ne vais
pas garder
dommage semblerait qu'on a raté une
marche
et oui tout simplement nous avons juste
de donner notre force notre énergie en
oubliant l'interprétation
nous avons oublié que ce fortissimo que
devant des classes daf de sur le
construire avec cet espace de liberté
qui est celui de l'interprète ne
s'agissait pas uniquement nourri aux
ordres d'exécuter s'est démarqué sur vos
consignes en partition les vient de
faire des choix on devait choisir entre
un fortissimo jouer parce qu'il tenait
le rôle que léo a au début bien
fortissimo menée par ceux qui jouent un
guillaume
on est comme vous quand on construit
d'avancé rien qui aurait fait rien on
choisit un but alors l'habitude des
séismes étaient en répétition passe
beaucoup de temps
enfin pour vous une toute première
version les touches qui jouent comme les
eaux
hormis blanc et ensuite une ovation glee
c'est beaucoup plus facile de choisir
quand on sait
[Musique]
bon on a choisi quelque chose on va
choisir maintenant la version non à
nouveau de faire moins d'efforts alors
qu' il est tout content de notre et à
lyon de se mettre en avant mais si c'est
pas très facile ce sera notre
interprétation du goût
[Musique]
le monde
nous
[Musique]
un travail après formé de musiciens
c'est apporter la lumière dans les
partitions grâce à nos choix et c'est
quelquefois difficile d'oser choisir en
fait compositeurs qui ont lu des textes
magnifiques dont on se sent on se sent
trop petit trop trop peu capable de
prendre ces décisions
et pourtant la pire des solutions sera
de ne rien choisir du tout donc
maintenant on sait que dans tous les cas
on boit pour la force intérieure de
prendre une décision
même quand on ne se sent pas très sûr
grâce à ces moments d'interprétation qui
aligne dans les éditions nous nous
sentons très maintenant à vous offrira
un beau morceau un beau morceau avec une
équipe performante pour chercher le
plaisir le plaisir à partager les bons
il s'agit d'un décès du batteur
américain de vengeance
[Musique]
où
on
[Musique]
m
et
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le mulet qui satisfait aux sages mais
pourtant je veux dire nos enfants et
notre maximum on peut encore ajouter
quelque chose il est un élément qui est
essentiel pour nous pour les plus loin
dans les changes avec un public
nous allons aller bien au delà de ses
savoir-faire que je vous explique depuis
le début de ce partage bien au-delà de
ses savoir faire c'est notre rôle
d'artiste qui est en question dans
l'entreprise denjean
nous voulons partager mais ces personnes
car c'est de nous écouter à quel point
finalement l'essentiel c'est la qualité
de présence formation scène quand on est
nouveau c'est la manière avec laquelle
nous allons aller chercher à l'intérieur
notre émotion l'authenticité et c'est
seulement parce que nous serons en
contact à titre individuel avec cette
dimension extrêmement fugace et
personnel que nous pourront toucher au
plus loin c'est en allant chercher au
plus profond que nous créerons un pont
le plus riche entre vous et nous avons
essayé de faire pour vous là dans
l'instant pour vous puissiez sentir à
l'impact de ce positionnement nous avoir
entendus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la qualité de ce nous recevrons par
votre silence par votre écoute et
cadeaux vous à continuer à travailler
dans cette ambiance il est vraiment
important pour nous de continuer aussi à
partager ces valeurs qui a mis notre
travail du savoir faire collectif à
l'authenticité la force de l'émotion
merci pour votre attention tennessee de
ceux de ce silence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]